welcome to episode 9 of let's play
politics you may notice that my game
looks a little bit better it's like the
shadows pop out a little bit more I
recently picked up the ambient occlusion
mode so that's why if you don't know
what it is it adds extra shaders to the
game which like eminent occlusion in
roller coaster q3 and much like I mean
in seclusion of Ilocos ii 3 i think it
really makes the game look a lot better
i've always been quite a big fan of the
very subtle graphic elements in park
tech like even though the graphics are
very simple you've got a very very
subtle bloom going on which you don't
notice really but when it wouldn't be
there it really makes a difference and
it's little things like that which have
always loved about the graphics and I
mean it's occlusion really fits it as
well
so I've got that and I actually had to
redownload the Dino Peck I have no idea
what was going on with this game but for
a while I couldn't get it to work and my
Malta was suddenly gone and I was very
confused but at some point I got it all
fixed what to do with the new launcher
of the park tech Nexus but for some
reason the ferns and some other elements
out of some of my croissants in resets
were just gone
but I did accidentally save the park in
that state so even after I read download
it that stuff all the friends were still
gone so that's why I was still going
through the entire park placing ferns
down everywhere where they where it
seemed like they kind of disappeared
you could really notice the ambient
occlusion by the way on underneath those
little trees that I placed over there
it's it's really quite obvious anyway
what I wanted to do in this episode was
to just finish this general area and
work on a station for the inverted
coaster which is something which I do
have to say I struggled with a lot and
even in retrospect I am really not too
happy with the station so far I have
been on a really bad streak I think with
creating stations and things like that
otherwise I feel like the park is it's
fine but when it comes to stations I
probably either need a little bit more
practice especially with the limited
tools that there are so far and perhaps
just should keep them a little bit more
simple something which I do wish to work
on in my next park I don't think any of
them are really
too bad by any means but it's not really
anything that I would be too proud of
but you'll see that in due time first I
wanted to finish the foliage over here
for this ride which is religiously and
standard foliage which I went for for
the rest of the park I had been thinking
that I might leave the area underneath
this right a little bit more open but
one of the things we just keep keeps me
from doing things like that is that I
feel like the transition from grass to
sandy textures is just way too sudden it
definitely works in cases like making a
beach or having a small Beach around a
lake or things like that but when it
comes to having very solid grass
underneath rollercoasters are making a
small field of grass just randomly
somewhere it's really just too sudden of
a transition or really the transition is
non-existent at least at the moment so I
just figured I would make it a forest
instead which I felt it's a little bit
too closed for this type of
rollercoaster but it's it is kind of
what I liked in the end and then the
color scheme has this really something
very standard arrow ish color scheme
probably the most common color scheme
that you'll ever see I just tried a
couple of other color schemes but since
I already had a coaster right next to
this coaster which handed rhetoric I
didn't want to have that not to mention
that there are some arrow loopers which
this one is way too much like actually
um which I'll talk about in a bit like a
Viper and American Scream machine which
you already have that same red color
scheme and didn't want to do that and I
figured purple would be perfect but the
jr coaster which i have next to it is
already purple so yeah my last sort of
choice there was blue and otherwise the
other colors really didn't work out but
yeah about the thing that the coaster is
very similar to coasters like well it is
almost viper really almost accidentally
and because i didn't actually want to
make it like viper and i didn't even
know what the exact layout of viper was
i just checked that i wanted to get to
know three loopings in there and i
wanted to get that element which i
forgot the name of that element where it
starts with the corkscrew and then two
half loops and then another and
the corkscrew I think it's the
Sidewinder but it probably isn't in any
case I wanted to get that element and
then a cork two corkscrews after that
but also a lot of messing around with
the layouts and changing some things and
rebuilding things I eventually very
accidentally actually ended up with a
layout that's ridiculously similar to
Viper so I do have to say it's I'm kind
of annoyed by that because I didn't even
memorize the layout of Vipers so either
like subconsciously I suppose I
recreated it or it just so happens to be
that this is the best way to kind of
bring those elements together because I
did want to follow the exact same set of
elements but in any case it's very much
like that coaster I suppose it happened
and I'm just gonna leave that in the
past and not worry about it too much
anymore but yeah it is way too much like
Viper way too much really ahem but this
station is something which I struggle
with a lot as well and one of the things
which in hindsight probably caused it
and what I shouldn't have done is the
fact that the station building is so
very high over here it's like it has an
elevation of just four I think now
actually it has an elevation of six I
believe and then the coaster track is
also very high when you compare to the
station itself so I had to raise all of
my walls quite a lot to actually make
that work which meant with the very
narrow footprint of this building which
is way too narrow compared to how high
it is that eventually whatever sort of
shape I would try out on it just kind of
doesn't work so as a small point of
feedback for my next bike I'll take with
me I suppose is that even if I add these
very high stations like this one I
should make this station a lot larger
and wider and add more to it because
otherwise it's gonna the the problem is
just that it doesn't really seem like
the proportions are right that's the
main problem that I have with it since
it's so very narrow compared to how high
it is and the thing is you can't really
mask the weird proportions of building
by making it look
- great by adding many details since
this simply isn't in the game so it's
some English I'm gonna have to pay a lot
more attention to later on not to
mention that I try to have a transmitter
I transfer truck over here with the very
limited space than I had and eventually
just was kind of forced to quickly
transfer track in the same building as
the station but as a result it's kind of
like a weird addition to this station
which doesn't really make too much sense
and I suppose you can have the transit
reckoning station very well but you
should if if you do that at least well
keep track of it god I shouldn't have
made a pun but actually I keep that in
mind and you know change the station
building accordingly and not just add a
random wing to it to fit the transfer
track in it that said I do kind of like
the final things around this station
building where I messed a bit with the
foliage and Garland's here but otherwise
it's something which I suppose is more
of a learning experience than anything
I'm really too proud of in this park and
truth be told I'm actually very much
looking forward to and be done with this
park that doesn't mean that I don't like
it at all anymore or I don't like
working on it it's do something which I
feel like I've done it nothing and I
kind of want to move over to a new theme
because one of the things which I really
do feel like it's like it's like I want
to try more new things and I'm sort of
ground to what I have in the park and
something a sort of theme and style then
I actually want to stay through - so you
know if I start a new park I can
actually just start completely and you
actually get some ideas and try out new
things which should be a lot of fun -
but yeah it's just gonna be one more
episode I believe so you finish this
Park and since I've been very true to
having about 10 minutes episodes except
for the fact that I actually was messing
around with the arrow layouts a lot
longer than I actually showed on the
video but I'm going to count that's I
once this is done in the next episode if
I get it done in the next episode
I've been working on this Park
approximately 20 hours so that's
actually something which I'm really
happy about mmm oh god I don't know
where that voice crack came from but it
mm [ __ ] all right that's actually
something which I'm very happy about
figuring that in park sex you can
actually make a complete park with a
reasonable amount of detail and foliage
in just about it's 20 hours
not counting and messing around with a
layout which doesn't really work which
is really good actually I'm very happy
with that it's a good time and it's one
of the things which I really like one of
the things which I always liked about
the original RCT games that you don't
get so lost in the detail but you can
just keep your focus on the overall park
as a whole and progress is just much
much faster than opposed to
rollercoaster c'n 3 while you really do
have to care about every detail which is
exactly where I feel like these games
kind of complement each other when it
comes to playing them but far from
replace each other since I really do
play rollercoaster get three more for
the attention to detail the individual
buildings or Gardens or parts of parks
and park tech for me is much more about
making an entire park and seeing it kind
of develop as the progress is just so
much quicker so that's really something
which was quite clear from almost
finishing this park not even being
finished yet and other than that I just
kind of wanted to finish these little
columns over here before I moved on
because the next thing that I'll do in
the next episode is make the station for
the arrow mega looper have that little
queue
connect to the paths and just finish the
foliage from there and then the entire
pod should be finished and there's no
real finishing touches or anything to
get to so that should be about it and
hopefully in time for the next update
too so thank you guys for watching this
episode and I'll see you guys on the
next episode Oh No whatever have a good
time